In this quiz, you're going to need
to add keyboard event listeners
to this collection of elements
with the class radiogroup.
Note that the individual radio
buttons have a class of radio.
The radio buttons are stored in
this.buttons within radiogroup.js.
There's also a focused index variable,
which is the index of the element
that should be focused.
There are already keyboard listeners for
both the up and left and down and
right arrow keys.
However, it's up to us to figure
out which index should be focused
when those arrow keys are pressed.
Keep in mind that there are only three
children, so if the index gets too high
or too low, we'll need to loop back
around in the other direction.
Once we've set the correct focus index,
the changeFocus method down here
should take care of the rest.